good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy thursday we have officially made
it to the latter half
of the week yeah yeah latter half
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah last half of the
week vibes guys
ladder [ __ ] half of the week
vibes what a special time of week once
again we have absolutely no choice but
to acknowledge the space that we're
currently in
and we are currently on the latter half
of the week we've got the fearless album
coming out tonight at midnight
good things are ahead everyone rejoice
thursdays are the day where we do
acknowledge the space that we're in
gladly yeah because there's so much in
front of us we go willingly into the
acknowledgement
right as opposed to the times when the
space is quite negative like a tuesday
that
really just like feels like it should be
a friday you know 100 percent
um we have a great show for you guys
today one because it's thursday two
because theo's here
and three because we're just like living
on this high of putting together
probably the most epic mukbang that
like the the internet youtube the
youtubers are [ __ ] quaking in their
studios
yeah it's true we filmed our mukbang
finally yesterday krispy kreme slash
beverly hills cafe
taste test um it will be going live
today it is ready for you it'll be up at
patreon.com morning toast you can watch
us
wolf down some sweet treats and really
like
so many of the sweet treats from our
past we're just bringing back kind of
all these memories for me
yeah and you'll you'll watch us go down
memory lane i personally found the
mukbang
experience quite stressful um it was
really crazy we had so
many sweets yesterday that i i actually
really felt it later in the day like i
was so
tired and like you you're watching the
video we definitely achieve a sugar high
for sure and then like later in the day
i was really coming down off the sugar
high and i'm like i
understand how sweets are just so not
good for you oh
i didn't really experience that i just
experienced like this eternal hive just
like being full on donuts
and i had the best time with the mukbang
like having to be
being forced to eat sweet treats for
your job like
okay i will be girl with a job any day
you know i went to live method
afterwards and i was like i just had
like i was like i'm sorry i ate a
doughnut i had to for work
yeah no it wasn't lying it's not our
fault that like our job is just like
so demanding of us so rigorous so
demanding so exhausting
it actually it was that was exhausting
it was really fun and it'll be up on our
patreon
so make sure to look out for that and
tons of new content coming at you this
month
yes definitely and in may and in may
you'll get it when you watch the video
yeah a little patreon inside joke
l-o-l but beyond that we have an amazing
show for you guys today the real
housewives of new jersey was on last
night and things got weird
so we are definitely going to be
discussing that in addition to all the
things happening on the earth last night
yes um lots of earth news you know like
lots of earthy news
people just like doing stuff making news
making waves yeah
and i think we should we should get into
it other than that i had
another busy day yesterday nothing much
nothing much to report
anything by you yeah actually i got home
from our mukbang
studio session and i plopped myself on
the couch
and i wanted to just like watch
something and i just like didn't care so
i just put something on
and when i opened netflix legally blonde
was like right up there so i'm like
perfect i haven't seen it in full in so
long
and it really is a feel-good movie it's
not one of those movies where everything
goes wrong like it's really like an
empowering movie
and i guess i haven't seen it in so long
that i had a kind of like a new
perspective on it
um because like as a as a kid i remember
watching and just being like l
is everything of the sort and of course
i still have that takeaway
but now as an adult i really realize
like how much of a role model l woods
was
like because she was like this girl who
was just like literally the definition
of everything of the story she was so
cute so beautiful
and really smart like she really just
when she put her mind to something she
just
she achieved it but she was also like so
nice like i feel like that's like a
forgotten quality of l woods like vivian
was the mean girl like l was always nice
to everyone
and you don't always associate like the
cool girl who like wears all pink as
like being the nice girl
but l was just breaking down barriers
and i feel like it's a really good movie
for young women to watch
i totally agree it was just so and also
hysterical like i was just
laughing laughing laughing yeah the
ammonium flag off light
yeah like just so good and so many stars
linda carlini chutney
yeah the role of a lifetime i thought it
was you walking through the front door
so good don't stop you little lassies
and products you should brooke
windenberg
okay literally okay thank you for
bringing that up
because her name was brook windham and
literally when i was thinking i'm like
why is that bronwyn windenburg
on my screen like the names were so
familiar and they like kind of look
alike it was such a weird coincidence
i'm so glad you brought that up yeah
hysterical hysterical
well i'm glad you enjoyed yourself just
a little update from me
screw sister never um
i've made a decision that i'm going to
go on my wellness retreat and now i'm
just
now i'm just setting out the right
location but i've come i've made
gone on the personal journey and i want
to just thank everyone for their support
the toasters have been
so supportive so encouraging and so many
people like reach out being like
i did like a similar experience when i
was no not even the program like i
decided to like go on a
trip by myself and it was the best thing
i ever did so
i'm gonna take a chance on me i'm gonna
do it and i will keep you all posted
um on the journey on the journey
fabulous but that also means you have
like three days of toast that you need
to film without me that's fine okay
um just once again like putting the
business on my back no i'm getting hello
um okay so now that like we're updated
with
with the crew yeah right anything else
we need to share i don't think so i mean
you guys just saw us yesterday no
the day before i know it's like hard as
a week goes on
less and like i have less will to live
it's harder for me to like keep these
updates so long because like
towards the end of the week like i
literally stare at the ceiling at night
like a day
the same as yesterday yes pretty much
except new outfit
new outfit new mukbang and we have a
great weekend ahead of us so i think
like
without further ado where are you
her name is velma or thelma i still
forget
um it doesn't matter at this point you
know you can like tell we're so fatigued
like
yesterday we're like without further ado
well i actually had like a traumatizing
night of sleep so like i'm feeling not
super well rested i went to bed so early
i was so proud of myself
and some time in the middle of my sleep
i felt someone standing over me
and you know that feeling like you feel
someone looking at you sure was someone
looking at you
and i literally woke up in a fright like
screamed at the top of my lungs
ben was on my side because i have a
water bottle on my side and he was
thirsty and he didn't have one
on his nightstand so i couldn't go back
to sleep after that like i was so shook
up like the feeling of waking up to
someone over you
that's so weird he could have gone to
the kitchen no and also like okay yeah
if you're getting up like go to the
kitchen get your own water
second of all if you're gonna take my
water take it don't drink it over there
because now that i think about it there
have been like a few times where i've
walked around to zach's side because
that's
where i know i left my water and i just
take it back to my side like a normal
person like a normal person that's
really sick he owes you an apology no i
know and like literally he texted me
this morning like the sun was shining
i'm like you
literally traumatized me last night like
it was such a horrible feeling
and i just couldn't shake it so like i
was up for a little bit now i'm feeling
kind of tired but what else is new even
if i had gotten 12 hours of sleep i
would still be tired so
totally but at least you have a good
reason yeah now i have a story yeah like
ben owes you big time sleep big time
okay without further ado
do here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
stamps.com let's face it make taking
trips to the post office is probably not
how you want to spend your time
that's why i recommend mailing and
shipping online at stamps.com
stamps.com allows you to mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer
send letters ship packages and pay a lot
less with discounted rates from usps
ups and more stamps.com has saved
businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
because with stamps.com you get the
services of the post office and ups
all at once plus big discounts on
mailing and shipping rates
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready just schedule a pickup or drop
it off it's that simple
and with stamps.com you get discounts up
to 40 off post office rates and up to 62
off ups shipping rates not to mention
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder nearly 1
million small businesses already use
stamps.com
so stop wasting your time going to the
post office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with promo code
toast you can get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage
and a digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in toast
that's stamps.com promo code toast
stamps.com
never go to the post office again now
that's something
now that's a promise worth keeping woo
okay first story we've got some
kardashian news one first up a follow up
from a story we reported on this week
khloe kardashian is breaking her silence
talking body image struggles after
unwanted photo saga
so if you listen to earlier episodes of
the toast you know that the kardashian
team was trying to get this photo of
chloe
taken off of the internet and they did a
somewhat successful job
yeah i only saw internet i guess like on
reddit or one of those channels
um and she posted on instagram last
night a number of videos of herself and
she even went live
showing off her physique she said hey
guys this is me
and my body unretouched and unfiltered
she said the photo that was posted this
week is beautiful but as someone who has
struggled with body image her whole life
when someone takes a photo of you that
isn't flattering in bad lighting or
doesn't capture your body the way it is
after working so hard to get it to this
point and then shares it to the world
you should ever
have every right to ask for it not to be
shared regardless of who you are
she talks about for those else who feel
the constant pressure of not ever
feeling perfect enough
i want you to know i see you and i
understand you every day i'm told by my
family and friends who love me that i am
beautiful
but i know that it needs to be believed
from within just do you and make sure
your heart is happy
she also talks about how you know she's
worked so hard to achieve this physique
and
for years she was referred to as the
ugly sister the fat sister she must not
have the same dad as them
right so like she got all of that
criticism she worked really hard on her
body and her image
to you know sort of book back at those
critiques and now everyone said she paid
for it it's surgery like
so she's damn if she does she's damned
if she doesn't and she's basically
telling everyone
to [ __ ] off yeah and i totally um
endorse that message
because it's very clear to me that all
of the kardashian girls kim and chloe i
feel like
come to mind most specifically have
really kind of been like
burned by the media and like how people
critique them especially like when kim
was pregnant
and it's obvious that they they talk
about their weight a lot they talk about
diet
dieting a lot like it's like obviously
something that's like kind of scarred
them so they just like do what they can
to be happy with themselves and like be
able to live with themselves and the
fact that like all these people are like
dying that they got like an unretouched
photo of chloe like oh our suspicions
are true like she really
doesn't look like that like it's just
annoying because and she said exactly
what what she said is exactly true like
regardless of who you are like
if there's a photo of you that you don't
like like you should have every right to
not want to share it
yeah and it sucks that like on the
platform that she's on like the second
it gets posted it lives forever in
perpetuity
but that sucks it does suck especially
for someone who's clearly struggling
like with body image she's like she's
clearly a victim
of this culture that's like so obsessed
with being skinny yeah
i feel bad for her i feel bad for her
too um
i just wish like everyone would [ __ ] off
like just leave
you know what i mean like it's it it
must be
so loud and deafening this sort of
criticism because they get criticism
about everything that they do
and they find a way to just move on and
tune it out but like it is probably
deafening for her that it actually
affects the way she sees herself yeah i
mean i think anyone knows
if you've ever like had someone say
something about your body in a negative
way like you know how damaging that is
even if it's just one time
so imagine that on a scale of millions
and millions of millions like it's not
it's not normal it's not healthy and of
course it's gonna like start to chip
away at you even the strongest person
can't withstand that many people like
telling you you're fat and ugly like
it's so traumatizing so
and then we get mad at chloe for not
being perfect with like how she edits
her photos but we [ __ ] destroyed her
so like
leave her alone like it's so stupid and
it's so unhealthy and like a lot of the
people who are commenting who are like
[ __ ] women like being like
do better chloe you [ __ ] do better
karen okay leave her alone
you know what if you want to morph
yourself into literally looking like a
cartoon
i empower you that is your right it's
your right to do so like everyone just
needs to leave everyone alone and stop
like
criticizing them okay maybe if you were
chloe you would handle it differently
but like you don't know what it's like
to be in that position
and for years have people just be like
criticizing you so hard and like
you're you're fat you're ugly and then
you get skinny you're too skinny oh your
body's fake you're morphing your photos
your photoshop your cartoon like
it's it's like you can't win so just
like [ __ ] off everyone just lay off like
i didn't even care that she that photo
got posted i didn't care that she looked
different like i just don't care
yeah like live your life i'll see you in
person one day
and i'll figure it out myself like i
don't [ __ ] care i do hope that this
whole saga puts to bed for once and for
all like this whole
narrative of like chloe's new face and
every time she posts a picture it's like
who is that it's like it's chloe with
her favorite filter on it move on
yeah like i am just no one to talk like
i filter the [ __ ] out of my photos and i
really feel empowered by it so
some people don't then don't do it then
don't do it then don't do it but like my
gums 110
yeah also a little kardashian news andy
cohen announced yesterday that he will
be hosting a keeping up
with the kardashians reunion on e he
said we're doing a keeping up reunion
covering all 20 seasons
hosted by me andy cohen get ready so the
whole family will be there
chris kim chloe courtney kylie kendall
and scott
no no rob and no kaitlyn and no kaitlyn
because caitlyn was like a huge part of
the show for a while yeah i feel like
the fact that scott well scott is a huge
huge part of the show like main
character
but because he's the only one who shows
up to film because he's in it it's like
oh the absence of rob is glaring the
absence of
everybody else is glaring but he has to
be in it because he is the show
but if it was just the girls you
wouldn't be like who's not there yeah
oh right of course i'm glad kylie's
gonna be there even though like i don't
know what she could possibly contribute
even though they are going over like the
all 20 years so like probably what it
was like to like go to school and then
like have cameras in your house even
before you were like famous
um i think this is great i love that
andy toasting it i did think their
announcement was incredibly bizarre like
with the fake face time like why didn't
they just actually facetime like it was
just like
like the most janky ass video yeah they
could have done like a
a successful announcement facetime i
agree i'm sure it was like someone's
like social media idea because like that
video of them facetiming had gone viral
and so they just injected themselves
they were like viral plus announcement
yeah it was weird yeah it was beneath
them in my opinion both andy and the
kardashians but regardless i will
definitely be tuning into this like love
a reunion style
show for the kardashians we never get
that but um i
i'm feeling like a little lackluster
about this because i do feel like we've
gotten some
we haven't had an andy hosted reunion
and if annie does what he does best like
it could be so
full of bombshells but we get a lot of
specials from like kim's birthday
special they always do like a christmas
special where they like re-watch old
footage and like laugh about it and it's
like really scripted and like
unnecessary
yeah and so if that's what they plan on
doing i'm good on them no i feel like
andy's involvement automatically like
elevates it to an actual like
substantial reunion with like good [ __ ]
in it
okay but like what what would you want
to hear him ask them just like going
over maybe
of like the most iconic fights and like
who and
i think he did a good job when he
interviewed them for for real i only saw
a few minutes of the clip
but he like was asking tough questions
and like courtney started going on this
rant about her her and kylie both feel
like they've both been given
such bad edits on the show like and andy
was like but you edit the show so like
he did get into the weeds on like things
that they've never spoken about and
things that i found to be really
interesting how does
kylie get a bad edit when she's not on
the show not on the show no right so
like i just feel like andy
will ask the person in questions like i
think andy being on it automatically
gives it like
stamp of approval from me i agree and
i'm going but they do do a bunch of like
[ __ ] specials for sure
right and so i'm just i'm a little
nervous that it's gonna be a [ __ ]
special but i'm going to
go in with open mind and an open heart
and love to see
my girls on the screen i have faith in
andy cohen i really do i don't think he
would attach himself to something like
trivial
i agree with that because his name
carries a lot of weight in the reunion
realm space yes i wonder how it's going
to be set up like is it couch
and three i don't know who would you put
on each couch it would be
chris kim
not in no particular order no no you
have to do the order too so chris and
kim can't sit on the same couch because
i think they would both be closest to
andy
yeah so i think it would be kim chloe
scott kylie kendall corning chris
courtney kendall kylie whatever
yeah i don't know i don't think they're
gonna sit in couch position because it
honestly like for us like we know what
it means you know what i mean and i
don't think they'll do that
so much maybe it'll just be like a round
table discussion or something
yeah or like all the girls on the couch
and then andy yeah whatever
either way exciting dude they didn't say
when it's dropping
no or where probably on a at the end of
the season
oh yeah which is on today oh it's on
tonight
addison rey um
no because he's soliciting questions now
got it oh i love
soliciting questions because the
audience is shady as [ __ ] and yes the
addison ray of it all i cannot
wait yeah it looks so good i hope it is
as good as it looks
me too it never is but are you ready for
our next story yes me
taylor swift and sophie turner are
talking about her new bop
sophie turner posted on her instagram
story taylor swift's new song mr
perfectly fine which is from the
fearless vault she said
it's not not a bop and then taylor
replied saying forever bending the knee
for the queen of the north
okay so for me like this is huge
because i think pretty much everyone
knows like a song that comes out of the
vault from the fearless era like
is about joe jonas like we woke up and
we decided to hate joe jonas again like
that's where we're at as
a fandom even though like we have moved
past it but i think the fact that sophie
posted about it like i
had thought this before i figured that
taylor probably called joe and sophie
and was like i have this song like it is
about joe but like we're so old now like
does it even matter and i think that he
probably
him and sophie probably gave her
permission to release it and then this
was like a coordinated pr thing to be
like we're all okay like there's nothing
going on here
taylor responded sophie posted like it's
all good it just happens to be about her
boyfriend from when she was 16
and like we're such different people
than we were when we were 16 like it
doesn't even count you know
yeah it was definitely like a
coordinated
moment yeah they definitely pre-empted
any sort of
chatter because that's not what i would
have ever thought and they wouldn't if
she puts out a song 15 years later i
wouldn't be like
she's hung up on joe jonas no she's not
and she definitely rewrote parts of it
like
at some point a song just becomes a song
it's no longer like a memory yeah
but i guess they are covering all their
bases they don't want any sort of drama
because it seems like everybody's
friends and now she says
sends his baby's presence and right and
when she posted that the song was out
she did an instagram story like
me in 2021 like writing songs about
fictional stories minding my own
business to avoid drama
taylor's song from 2008 screaming from
the vault let me out
so like she's acknowledging that like
it's really not about that so and for
the most part like nobody's coming for
joe jonas being like you are mr
perfectly fine like no
no one's doing that like thank god so it
seems like we've all found peace
which is great alexa play peace by
taylor swift you know yeah um but the
song is so good like
that's exactly what i was hoping for
from the vault you all over me is good
too but it's not really like a bop you
know
this is like a bop and a half and it's
really good the album comes out tonight
are you excited are you staying up how
are you celebrating the thing is it's
like
i know every word to every song on
fearless like i don't really need to
stand up there's more vault tracks
there's more of all checks there's the
keith urban collab which is [ __ ]
crazy and i'm curious to see like what
kind of changes she makes like i
literally want to go
over like listen to the album with like
the lyrics in my hand just to see like
the different changes because
i have a call and i just want to put it
out in the universe like just in case it
comes true and i said it to margo so she
has like proof that i said it
and you're going to put more proof now
yeah so there's evidentiary support
evidentiary support behaviors corpus
so there is a song that's the way i
loved you and it's so good and there's a
line in the second verse that goes um
he's wait he's that's the way i loved
you already a song
yes that's the way i loved you
breaking down and coming undone it's a
roller coaster kind of rush and i
never knew i could feel that much and
that's the way i loved it
it's one of the best ones in my opinion
thinking stunning the love
down so in this whole song is basically
about how like
she has this boyfriend like he's great
he's fine but like he's not you know
screaming and fighting and kissing in
the rain and it's 2 a.m and i'm cursing
your name
she misses like the drama of it all but
in the verses she's like describing him
and in one of the verses she says
he's close with my mother and talks
business with my father
and i just feel like new era like
feminist taylor is gonna be like he's
close with my father and talks business
with my mother because like
andrea swift first of all like literally
runs taylor's like
and co she's like truly a businesswoman
and i just feel like she's gonna make
that change and i just want to put it
out there
just in case i feel like it's like a
possibility it's a really good call
right and i feel like if she doesn't
then she'll
watch this and be like [ __ ] i should
have done that i'm doing another album
yeah right like taylor's version times
two and you this was
just totally i swear to god like i was
just listening to a whisper
nope nope nope like i was just thinking
that's such like a kind of like
provincial is that the right word like
antiquating yeah but provincial is an
interesting word it's just like an
antiquated
song lyric when taylor was writing like
country music in the early 2000's like
that was a perfectly fine lyric
but now and i mean it's still perfectly
fine but i think it is
that she would rather switch it up and
like that's the message she wants to put
out there and it's true like her mom
really does like run her whole company
like her mom is literally like
ceo of taylor swift incorporated so i
just think that
it's one of my ideas that i'm putting
out there also
i meant to mention this i watch mary
queen of scots and joe alwyn is in it
yes and i didn't like i was looking at a
man on the screen
he plays lord dunlee
um and i was looking at the screen i was
like that's a handsome man
and then later i was looking at the cast
and it said joel and i was like who's
shown in this i'm like he's a handsome
man
and that was the first time i've ever
really watched something with him in it
i know he's only in like really fancy
british movies like
the favorite like i've never seen him
and actually act in anything
now like my rabbit hole has converged
with
joe always this catalog this isn't the
last time you're gonna see joe alwyn
because you are now living in his world
like
i entered joe allen's world and so
it just made me really excited that is
exciting i've never seen him on screen
like ever
you might not recognize him he had brown
hair in the movie and he was just
looking really cute
oh my god brown hair yeah no it really
worked for him
um but so back to this phyllis comes out
tonight like i really am so so
so so so excited i'm so happy she didn't
start with the debut album because while
it's good like
this is better and i'm just like living
for it yeah i agree
okay are you ready for our next story
yes some exciting documentary news
netflix buys kanye west docu-series
21 years in the making for a reported 30
million dollars
this doc has been in the world since
before the birth of yeezy i agree
because it's literally going to be a
series they have
years worth of footage everything over
the last 20 years they have
um stuff from like his mom's
passing stuff with kim like literally 20
years of his career
on footage and we also have known that
like he films himself
right we know that from the taylor swift
gate this is like gonna be
sick it's gonna be like seasons and it's
gonna it's gonna be like a show
it's gonna be yeezy season seasons
literally but it's gonna be a show
but it's a reality show but in the past
no i know and like
honestly i just thought 30 million
wasn't a lot just given what netflix has
paid for some other things like
i like kind of my frame of reference is
always like jerry seinfeld's
got paid 60 million dollars for like a
one-hour comedy special which is so
absurd yeah but
um insiders told variety that it's not
an accurate figure
so it's oh it's up for discussion oh
okay okay okay it was like for sure i
saw it at 30 million everywhere
it's not confirmed says one insider got
it well i'm curious like if kim will be
involved in anyway like will she have a
say and how she's portrayed
kim has always protected kanye when it
came to the e-show so like i wonder if
he'll have the same kind of
respect for her well he's not involved
in the production but he
has given the producers his implied
consent for them to move forward with
the project by granting him
them access to his life but he's not
like cutting and pasting
interesting yeah which i think will
probably be best
i would go for either but that way if
it will be what it is yeah okay well i
will definitely be watching that
and that's very exciting like good for
netflix because honestly it's been a
while since they had something like
that's worthy like i could really like
live without my netflix account like
that's where i'm at now mm-hmm
i feel you except they had broke back
mountain earlier in the week and i
really enjoyed that movie
yeah but i'm sure i could've got it
somewhere else i'm sure are you ready
for our next story which is some
good news that is so [ __ ] cute and
sweet good news that is so [ __ ] cute
and sweet [ __ ] yeah
shaq have you seen this of course shaq
surprised a young hard-working kid by
paying for his engagement ring at an
atlanta jewelry store when he overheard
him put it on
layaway so the video was the moment was
caught on camera where the generous
moment shaq hands his credit card to
azales store clerk
to purchase the ring was posted to
instagram on a fan page on tuesday and
quickly went
viral in the instagram post shaq can be
seen shaking the stranger's hand and
patting him on the back as he covers the
cost
for the ring do you know how much it was
no after it was posted shaq addressed
the clip on
tnt tuesday and said he just happened to
be shopping for hoop earrings
at the atlanta jewelry store when he
overheard the stranger who he described
as a young hard-working guy
asking to make a layaway payment on the
ring when he decided to step in
so i said tell your girlfriend i got it
i'll take care of it shaq did not
disclose the price tag but said the
amount was not much for him
at first the stranger resisted but he
told him not to worry he does it all the
time
i'm just trying to make people smile
that's all so apparently shaq does this
all the time like when he's out and
about
randomly paying for stuff random acts of
kindness paying for stuff for people i
love them
and it's literally the sweetest story
the only thing is like
in the time this video went viral like i
don't think the guy had a chance to
propose
but like i think like if i'm his
girlfriend like i don't care yeah but
just like the surprise is spoiled
oh my god that's such a good one like
the guy who ran home and did it
immediately
that's not how it works no no but maybe
he knew like the video was taken it was
going to make its way around so he had
to
do it fast get down to it literally
honestly shaq is probably one of my
favorite type of celebrities for a
multitude of reasons one because i just
love people who are like generous
and of course like generous and you know
writing big checks to fancy charities
but also like boots on the ground just
like helping people out paying for
groceries like
i love that tyler perry does that a lot
too like i just love that
i love shaq because he also um probably
does the most endorsements of any
celebrity i've ever seen in my entire
life
but it doesn't become annoying like his
commercials are hilarious for carnival
cruises and the general insurance like
he's so funny and then three like he's
really good at his job like
he is hysterical ben isn't always he's
on jj that's the other thing like he
follows his passions he's a [ __ ]
great dj he follows his passion
but he's also
first shack in all the celebrity
categories like he checks every box for
me
totally and this story just warms the
heart it seriously does
it does it's such a sweet thing to do
like to pay for someone's engagement
ring yeah it's such a big expense
yeah no it's it's really such a mitzvah
mm-hmm i'm really
like in love with chad he's a mensch
check of a girlfriend
i don't know could be her could be me
could be you
are you ready for a fifth and final
story a little biz news a little fifth
and final story
a little biz news yeah of course
it's some serious biz twitter held
discussions for a four billion dollar
takeover
of clubhouse
think about it twitter held talks in
recent months to acquire clubs
[ __ ] does twitter have four billion
dollars beats me the buzzy audio based
social network according to people
familiar with the matter the companies
discussed a potential valuation of
roughly four billion dollars for
clubhouse
the people said asking not to be
identified because the matter is private
discussions are no longer ongoing and
it's unclear why they stalled the people
added
but interessant that twitter was
interested in clubhouse
and would value it at 4 billion instead
they just stole the idea and came up
with twitter voices that absolutely
nobody uses they have their own like
clubhouse thing
it's so unpopular like a kid but so
twitter that's
so twitter it's corruption
ideas um it is really interesting that
clubhouse is valued at four billion
dollars but like that's how tech works
like you get one person on your platform
and suddenly you're a billionaire so
like
we got into the wrong space um clubhouse
like is popular it's still very niche
and it's still in beta like you still
have to be invited
but i'm so over it like i can't even
begin to describe how over clubhouse i
am
i i like the idea i like that it's
happening i i personally
just can't give much of myself to it
um and so
i'm happy for i'm happy for everyone i
just found it to be like
really kind of boring yeah but maybe we
were just like being boring and in
boring rooms
we're not boring though that's the thing
and we're audio queens we're audio
queens and we're not boring so like i i
know what we are and i know what we ate
and we ain't boring
that's true so even just like all of us
me you
margo lauren elizabeth like that's we
literally facetime all the time the four
of us
and it's exciting as [ __ ] that's true so
like
yeah something's not connecting for us
in our space but it's connecting for
many others
speaking of lauren elizabeth she just
got back on her podcast she took a
little break
she's been releasing like fire [ __ ]
content on her youtube out of all
cylinders like
youtube instagram and her podcast mood
with lauren elizabeth
new episodes drop every wednesday a new
episode came out yesterday highly
recommend checking it out
definitely um so should we dive into our
tv recap segment i feel ready
i do i need to i need to go back to toms
river
yes to the jersey shore um the real
hofstras of new jersey recap is brought
to you by betterhelp
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
yes i would say depression anxiety just
to name a few
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it is professional counseling done
securely online
there's a broad ranges range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and
financial aid is available betterhelp
wants you to start living a happier life
today
you can visit their website and read
their testimonials that are posted daily
and if you want to visit betterhelp.com
toast that's better
h-e-l-p you can join the over a million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
so today's episode is sponsored by
better help and toast listeners can get
10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com toast that's 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
toast okay so let's go back to
tom's river we picked up last night's
episode
of the dinner the pizza dinner oh my god
the two tables like i get that it's
covered but it's so stupid oh my god
stupid but
also it could only happen on this
franchise it worked
yeah um and things like were just like
being weird between joe and melissa and
like honestly i never expected that like
from turn of events jersey franchise
like if there's one certain thing i know
it's like joe and melissa are solid and
like they're not
and they're otb but it's it's tough but
i feel like they've always been really
public about their
arguments and the things that are sort
of bubbling beneath the surface but the
fact that they've been open about it
like means that it's not really cause
for concern the fact that he's like
why are you always working blah blah
like it's almost just a trope of their
marriage but like things just got weird
twisted
and they were fighting excuse me in
front of their house guests which like
is so awkward and then like when joe
when melissa's in her bedroom so jackie
and margaret go to check up on her
and then joe comes in and like jackie
melissa at first like don't leave it's
like
like this is not a group discussion i
know but i feel like it also shows how
genuinely close they all are
and that they have like a real
friendship almost like a family where
you you don't have to hide from them
like you're probably going to wind up
telling them about it anyway so if
people
witness it yes it is like bad if you're
doing that in front of other people but
i think it also just spoke to like
the fact that they really all trust each
other like as couples i agree
it was just like not something i would
literally ever do like even with you
guys actually no i'd do with you
of course he would yeah but like it's
just weird yeah no i think everybody was
really
uncomfortable um but it also felt like
the next day
joe kind of understood that he was in
the wrong and was controlled he wasn't
like doubling down so
maybe he's like just drunk and emotional
and
that was just like the worst side of him
coming out like i mean
it's it's weird because whatever he's
like there's two things first of all i
think like the walking in front thing is
literally the dumbest thing but then
also he's now
saying that like melissa's fame is like
affecting their relationship and that's
not something as viewers
that we would ever really see because
we're
like that's like a fourth wall that we
can't even begin to understand so that
was like a crazy accusation
yeah and and we're in no place to judge
right we don't know if it's true
like yeah but that was famous for a long
time so like
what happened and also but then it also
was like he's saying in the last year
things have been tough and i think
things have been tough for a lot of
people in the last year so it's not just
that
your wife is famous like it's a lot it's
that we're all stuck in the house
together
right she's been famous for almost 10
years now and it never affected your
relationship so i don't think that's
what it is me too but let's look at like
one of these things is not like the
other and it's the fact that you guys
are spending every day together day in
day out
in lockdown and that's not really
healthy for a relationship i also felt
like when theresa found out about the
fight like she was literally getting
like too excited about it like
like she just like you should feel
sadness like if your brother and his
wife are
going through a tough time but she was
like no i mean just like my next husband
and i want to be like just like joe like
really affectionate really
like she saw last week's episode of the
toast and then was like i'm gonna double
down i'm taking in love with my brother
yeah no
nothing that happened in last night's
episode made me um
question anything that we said no she
was just like getting too much joy out
of their misery and then like
she's in love with her mother like yeah
but also it's like she's kind of in like
or i don't want to say in love but
she really likes to like parade herself
in front of like all of the women's
husbands it's so inappropriate it's a
really annoying trait in a friend
lala kent when she took her boobs out no
it's not the same thing because
it's like she was in the moment and
maybe was inappropriate in the moment
but that's not how she is
every single time she sees the husbands
but like whenever any one's man is
around she's like in her baby voice
whether it's frank
ben because he reminds me of bruce oh
joe you're wearing pineapples for me
right she does it with frankie time when
she like comes down in her little outfit
like it's fine with frank because he's
like nobody's husband yeah she's even
like that with evan she's like within
her little baby
so disgusting it's so inappropriate i
could never
have a friend like that ever it's it's
uncomfortable and it's like weird like
what are you doing
like i fully respect and like um
have empathy for the fact that like it
must be really hard to like be the only
single one like
even dolores doesn't have a david around
but she has frank like
theresa is so obviously single and
that's tough for sure and like i think
they all coddle her a little bit but she
takes it a little too far
yeah she does it's just like
it's a weird it's a weird thing to do
and it's not just because you're the
only single one
that's not the default no that doesn't
mean you could like be freaky around
everywhere like talk about how you want
your peach eaten like it's disgusting
thank you yeah thank you yeah and also
i'm not realizing that her tagline is
like also disgusting
people say starting over but i say
starting over never tastes
so good yeah she keeps talking about
getting her like a vag eaten so like
that must be what it's referencing right
i guess so the bad i guess so i've been
focused on top
quality fabrics but i think
that that's all so i think there's like
a hidden meaning yeah
she's like she left us an easter egg
like taylor swift so yeah yeah it's so
subtle
so the episode was fine i feel like the
um memorial for no no like
hardcore got me like choking no i know i
know i can't
i couldn't like go like i was not in the
mood to like
be so emotional but like when it's when
no one's on the screen you have no
choice but to cry and when g is like
just on the screen like choking up and
then like flashing back to literally
like 15 years ago like
it is so emotional and like you can't
deny how sad it is and like
i don't know just like the way they talk
about their parents with such respect
and such love and like the way they talk
about their marriage how like they're up
in heaven like they're better together
and like they were so in love
and i think joe kind of uses that as
like an excuse like being saying to
melissa
but it is really sweet like how much
respect and love they have for their
parents like up until the end and
it's just like it was really sweet it
was really sweet when jesus it was a
nice party when jesus said she was going
to say something i was like
waking up thinking about so many things
thinking about monona today i feel like
if if that had been filmed when that had
already gone viral she
might have gotten in on the joke yeah
yeah i think she loves it
each other social media will smith has
been using party be like she's a star
she is a star it must be so cool so
exciting for her
i thought the party was like really nice
like a lovely way to honor someone's
life
it was beautiful it was truly a
celebration of life yeah it was a big
ass party it was a big ass party and
they did not
make it a big deal but i did notice that
they were all taking a shot of johnny
walker blue which i guess was known as
favorite
margaret josephs who does not drink took
the shot that's so good i thought it was
so sweet like i wish they made it like a
bigger deal i'm like margaret
are you drinking like she does not drink
yeah
that's really sweet i know um the fight
between margaret and jennifer sort of
simmer down which i'm glad for but i
feel like it's definitely gonna come
out it's bubbling yeah they put it aside
for
now which was respectful but like and
also i thought it was actually very very
sweet of
um dr aiden
and jennifer to get that gift from
melissa and joe that painting it was
really sweet yeah
so like there's sides of jennifer i like
honestly it's mostly when she's with
bill
because when he was putting on her shoes
like i was dying that's so cute they're
truly so cute i know but her on her own
she's a beast like i can't stand her
yeah also when they were at that
restaurant they'd like
pull up in your boat restaurant just
like having a funny day
it's like these people are genuinely
friends like you
without the cameras like that's a table
you would walk past and they're just
like having a great time
agreed and that's what makes the show so
good and the husbands really just add
that's what really makes this franchise
stand out more than any other franchise
it's like
they're the most involved i heard read
like a rumor on like a blog that they're
literally getting a spin off like that's
how interesting they are but like i
don't even want to spin off like i just
want them to keep being with the women
on the show and i think that that makes
new jersey like it's so special yes so
special it's really true like
everyone else i think at this point like
other cities the casts
are friends because like that's what it
is but these are people like
cameras up cameras down like we're going
ride or die and we're having a great
time
yeah so they make it really special and
i just
i literally love them so much and i
can't decide like which one i would want
to be married to like
i think sometimes evan and then i think
sometimes frankie tania and then
sometimes i think joe
and then no i'm saying joe and nick now
oh okay no but sometimes it's joe gorga
because he's really the key
the number one guy in this yes yes and
he is just hysterical and keeps the
party going and so like
sometimes i'm like joe burger but then
after last night like i don't know
i don't know i also don't like this
narrative that's like starting to bubble
up of like the men and women just both
like being like
yeah joe wears the g-string and margaret
wears the pants like it's so
disrespectful to talk about someone's
marriage like that and maybe i'm just
sensitive because like i ride or die for
margaret it's so [ __ ] hard
but like i can just imagine like someone
saying that about like my marriage and
it would really offend me and like
embarrass me so like i just don't like
that people are talking about like that
but it seems like this group is like so
involved in each other's business
yeah maybe it's like natural but like it
just feels very rude to me no and also
it's very archaic like right no one
would say that if
if they thought joe benigno was wearing
the pants in the relationship no one
would say that
yeah they don't say that about dr bill
and right so
jennifer yeah i agree yeah but a lot of
like the old school italian
is very like traditional and that's like
what the whole fight with joe and
melissa is like i want you to stay at
home and make meatballs
while i go to work and provide yeah and
then melissa's like i have a store now
like
time's starting and by the way melissa
said that on our show and i never forgot
it because i thought it was such an
interesting take
on how like a lot of the people who come
on housewives like are
housewives by definition like they cook
they clean they pick up the kids they
are caretakers
um and then like the show gives them
like a sense of
purpose beyond their families and it
gives them like a platform and a job
and then it makes it difficult in a lot
of marriages and she had said that and i
thought it was such an interesting take
now i'm realizing it's because she was
speaking from experience yeah no but it
definitely it changes the nature of
their relationship yeah
when you're used to one thing and
something else happens but i just
thought by now they would have figured
it out yeah yeah and it doesn't always
have to be a bad thing but that's why i
think there's like more to it than just
like the typical you're at envy all the
time also like everyone's working from
home what are you referring to what red
carpets
is she going appearances right so like a
year ago if you had this fight i would
get it but like
this year just doesn't seem to apply so
that's why i just think there's like
something brewing yeah something else
um but i think i think they're a great
couple i think it's fine i think it's
fine too i hope i love them they're
really like the heart and soul of the
whole group like
they are the heart and soul if they got
divorced like it would be a good
show because it would be like who's
taking whose side the men and it's
so tangled but they really are like the
heartbeat of the show like they are
everyone's always at their house like
they are the center yeah like
yeah and because like joe gets the guys
together and they feel like all
those guys are great together but on
their own like you know he's like
the personality the ring leader and
melissa really ties the group together
because they would be so divided if she
wasn't related to theresa and they had
no choice but to hang out
yes so because jackie and margaret would
never never hang out with those other
women so
oh well dolores is great too i i love
dolores
with every episode she just has like
moments of just pure gold
when she said when she was just trying
to like get joe back to earth and was
like
this girl's like obsessed with you like
she dies through like chill the [ __ ] out
like it's not that deep like
that was really nice of her to like
insert herself in and i love delores
and the only time it's frustrating to be
a dolores fan is like when she's blindly
defending
teresa which she hasn't done as much
this season but in seasons past it's
been
so frustrating yeah no she's not doing
that decision she's just staying out of
it which
i appreciate as well me too but i do
like want some of her hot takes and like
i feel like
she actually is like a good like moral
compass and i would like for her to
insert herself a little bit more
yeah like what do you think she's just
not that way no but i think a lot of the
times she doesn't insert herself because
if she had to decide who was right
her friends would be wrong right
jennifer and teresa so she's the two
most wrong people so she stays out of it
but she's
but it works it works so tonight is
keeping up with the kardashians we will
recap that tomorrow
for friday friday gotta get down
on friday we've got to get down don't
you forget to get down
look out on our patreon channel the vlog
will be up anytime this afternoon
and we think you guys are going to love
it so thank you guys so much for
listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cats box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning shows live five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing thursday stay safe and we
will see you tomorrow
[Music]
bye